- [Voiceover] If x is equal to 20,
so this right over here
is a 20 degree angle
and this one also is a 20 degree angle,
and y is equal to 30,
so this right over here, we'll
do this a different color,
this right over here is,
I'm having trouble switching colors,
that's a 30 degree angle.
In the figure above, what is
the value of z right over here?
This is a little bit strange at first
because it feels like
we might be able to use
triangles somehow, but this
whole shape is not a triangle.
But, if we could construct a triangle or
we know two of the angles of the triangle,
then we know we can always
figure out the third
because we know the sum
of the interior angles
of a triangle add up to 180.
So, can we construct a triangle where
we know two of the angles?
So, let's think about it.
So, this is, we know this is 30 degrees.
We know this is 20 degrees.
Can we construct a
triangle where these are
two of the angles of that triangle?
Well, what if we,
what if we extend this side
to go all the way over here?
Now we have, we know two of
the angles of a triangle.
Now, we should be able to figure out
this third angle right over here
and what is a third angle going to be?
Well, 30 degrees plus
this angle plus 20 degrees
is going to be 180,
or another way to think about it,
this is going to be 180 degrees,
minus 30, minus 20
or this is going to be
180 degrees minus 50.
So, this is going to be 130 degrees.
Now, if we know that, we can figure out
what this angle's going to be because
these two angles are supplementary.
They are going to add up to 180 degrees.
When you go all the way
around, you've essentially,
you've gone all the way
or you go halfway around
the circle or you can kinda say
the two rays of the angle form a line.
And so, what plus 130 is 180.
Well, 180 minus 130 is 50 degrees.
So, this is 50 degrees, what do we know,
what do we know about this angle
right over here?
Well, 50 plus 20 plus
this is going to be 180.
So, another way of thinking about it,
this is going to be 180 minus 50,
minus 20 or 180 minus,
what is this, minus 70.
So, this is going to be 110 degrees.
Well, if that's 110 degrees,
now we're really cutting
to the chase 'cause this,
that angle, that angle is supplementary
with the angle that has measure z degrees.
So, we know z plus 110, z plus 110
is going to be equal to 180
or subtract 110 from both sides.
You get z is equal to 70
and we're done.